lights in the sky form patterns scatter
and move in perfect sync as if
controlled by an invisible hand so will
you flip it's impossible you just can't
explain it you start to speculate they
may be balloons or you may be there are
cranes controlling these lights are
crane a gift but then they rotate and
fly over and around each other and you
run out of explanations that's when
technology becomes magic opieop tompa
talking to Markie what you can't see in
the dark the tiny lights are LEDs
attached to quadrocopter little drones
that move through the sky almost
noiselessly they were developed by the
ars electronica institute's future lab
in Linz Austria the drones bodies are
produced by a German company the lab
created the light designs called spec
says itself
its tongue I'll if our pups removal they
can produce any hugh de la florist we
run them through a test routine there's
talking as white then r g and b red
green and blue on the kannada if I lip
reading foul and using those three
colors we can create any colors we like
farm the drones are lined up in rows
before they're launched the
choreographies are done using a software
the team developed themselves which also
keeps the drones from crashing and mid
air every few seconds a GPS system
updates the computer on each drones
position which did elevational computer
on the ground communicates with each
drone and directs its positions at that
point we're only really on hand to
monitor things the swarm act
autonomously in conjunction with a
computer which just runs through its
programming fully got the norm on sport
San become sort of sum up the challenge
is to keep them up in the air in their
correct formation problems are often
caused by the wind if one of the drones
crashes a 3,500 euro piece of technology
is wasted so far there's been no serious
damage the first show in 2012 and linds
was a big success almost 50 drones took
to the sky at the same time a world
record yet to be broken soon more
requests started coming in
for example from Mao in Sweden for the
ceremony launching its year as european
capital of culture in 2014 or from
australia where the team drew a kangaroo
over the skies of brisbane specs is also
added some real razzmatazz to a stage
show in sharjah in the united arab
emirates some people wonder if the
mysterious flying lights are objects
from another world this perfume Evita is
asked if that happens all the time
reports keep showing up in the press
about people in the neighborhood where
we've been flying the drones having
cited UFOs I think it's fantastic a lot
of this is fantastic Nell future lab
operates a fleet of 75 drones but they
have yet to take to the skies all at the
same time India you certainly spooked in
the more of these points of light in the
sky the more means of expression and
ways to vary them you've got the system
Phillips the system as it exists right
now could easily handle one or two
hundred vehicles and we've set ourselves
that goal we intend to achieve that and
more the fleet of drones is set for
launch soon this time on course for the
United States on a mission to dazzle
audiences with their bright
choreographies
you